do you ever find yourself trying to
concentrate yet can't seem to focus why
are we so distracted these days here are
a few techniques I discovered in my
research that can help us stay on track
I used to think that just by writing
things down they'd get done but of
course I go from day to day to day
recycling the bottom half of my to-do
list because I wasn't making time to do
those tasks so the best place to start
is not with the output of what you want
to get done every day but with the input
of how much time you have to devote to
every task
if you enjoy using social media that's
great but make time for it in your day
so it's not something you're only using
every time you feel bored or lonely
for example if you start checking your
email on the way back from a meeting and
you're finally at your desk and you keep
checking your email instead of getting
to the task at hand well now that
liminal moment has turned into a
distraction so be careful those times
when you're transitioning from one task
to the next